c'est pas obligatoire pour le moment
la base du volontariat c'est pas gênant
mais on le sait bien mais il faut pas là
commencé en décembre non mais attendez
sur la base du volontariat chaque parent
prend ses responsabilités j'ai aucune
difficulté avec ça on sait très bien
comment ça commence la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est que c'est que c'est
sur la victimisation obligatoire des
adultes ou en tout cas la question de la
vaccination des adultes qui ne sont pas
convaincus parce qu'aujourd'hui à la
vaccination obligatoire moi en tout cas
je si je devais choisir si je devais
choisir entre la vaccination obligatoire
des adultes et la vaccination de tous
les enfants je préfère la vaccination
obligatoire des adultes alors même que
on commence à dire que peut-être au
micron n'est pas sensible à cette
vaccination alors on n'est pas un moment
un peu compliqué l'an l'enjeu aussi pour
nous c'est l'efficacité des vaccins on
voit bien on a eu tout un débat sur la
question la vérité c'est que c'est sur
l'efficacité de cette fixité des vaccins
aujourd'hui on voit bien que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont fait la
troisième dose ont un taux de protection
beaucoup plus important et que donc
aujourd'hui le vaccin et notamment le
rappel troisième dose à une efficacité
certaine dans ce delta sur le delta pour
moi avoir ensuite effectivement sur le
ch le nouveau variant il ya aussi des
recherches qui continue en parallèle là
dessus mais on le voit bien tant que
nous avons quasiment que des non
vaccinés en réanimation tant que les
formes graves au que le vaccin protège
des formes graves il faut de toute façon
accélérée la vaccination et notamment
pour les publics fragiles il ya encore
beaucoup de personnes âgées qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et que là il ya un enjeu de
société extrêmement important
[Musique]